I'm Danica Patrick and I'm pretty
intense I had a very special experience
of being able to meet His Holiness the
Dalai Lama and that is really his
message is to have everyone be able to
get along and have there be tolerance
for difference and tolerance for you
know I I have heard that you know there
are you know people that practice other
religions that come to your synagogue
and - so it's kind of interesting
because you came from a background of
being more of an atheist really from
what I understand right for many years
and then going into religion
specifically and diving all the way in
and believing much more in religion and
really not in spirituality so you know
here I'm looking at these messages on
two different religions and you having
this very inclusive demeanor to you so
but yet you're fixed on religion let me
tell you my problem with spirituality is
opposed to religion first of all I
wouldn't say I believe in religion and
not spirituality okay
I think spirituality is an essential
part of religions to the core
my problem with spirituality is alone
when people say I'm spiritual but not
religious I always want to ask them how
much do you give to charity because
religion is the organized community's
response to the promptings of
spirituality so I know in my synagogue
there are people who suffered losses the
community brings them meals the
community supports them the community
checks in with them the community visits
them because that's what religion does
but if I say I'm a spiritual person what
obligations do I have as a result of
being spiritual none but if I say I'm a
religious so-and-so a religious
so-and-so has to do the following things
and I'm always suspicious of things that
make us feel good about ourselves but
don't obligate us to do something for
someone else and that's why I think it's
dangerous to say what's matters of
spirituality and not religion because
that's saying what matters is feeling
and not action
I don't totally agree because I don't
think that I don't think that well so
here's how I would describe and again
I'm by no means in your position I've
had my own history and lineage of where
I've gone in my life with religion being
in and out but to me spirituality is
saying I don't attach myself to one
religion spirituality is saying I
believe in a collective and a collective
idea or you know so it's not that I
don't believe I should give I absolutely
give to charity
I was absent no I people say they they
shouldn't give I'm saying spirituality
alone doesn't contain those obligations
and to say I didn't know that there was
really like an obligation to give even
if I was in religion like I wasn't rude
like I mean some
well Catholicism don't you pass around
the plate yes and your spirit if your
spiritual nobody's giving you a plate
right that's true and that's that that
to me is the difference and it almost
like when people say I pick and choose
from different religions I want to say
to them almost you don't speak lots of
languages at once you speak a spiritual
rather religion is a language it's
Judaism as the language I speak to God
other people speak other languages
mm-hmm but the more you know your
language and the deeper you go into it
the more you can express I think I can
be more universal the more Judaism I
know so for me you got to go deep not
broad I'm sure that in your sport you
had to have a deep and detailed
knowledge that's what made you excellent
you couldn't say yeah I think I'll get
in a car and drive around you had to
really know it so I think when someone
really knows their tradition if they
have deep roots that's what gives you
broad branches
you